uh guidance that will be followed here
in the white house is washington dc is
now not only
recommended anymore
sure well we are evaluating our
protocols obviously this guidance is
just going out now as we speak i believe
dr wolenski continues to provide a
briefing call with some of your
colleagues right now dc currently has a
mask mandate until march first we have
always followed the most stringent
guidelines that has typically been the
cdc so we will plan to follow that and
in the meantime we are evaluating our
protocols here at the white house
he did uh in the the president of this
phone call with him did it come up uh
whether president biden bring up whether
president
he thinks he should leave the country or
not
uh
that that is not i don't have any
additional details to provide uh
president zielinski continues to serve
as president of ukraine he continues to
do that courageously in the face of
attacks from russian military this was a
call for the president to reiterate our
strong support for him for the ukrainian
people and to reiterate and condemn the
actions of the russians on sanctioning
putin and lavrov yesterday president
biden had said that that was on the
table what changed between yesterday and
today well it has been under
consideration and on the table for some
time as you know and uh as i just
conveyed uh the president's
strong view and strong principle from
the beginning of this conflict and even
before i should say has been to take
actions and steps in alignment with our
european partners and this is certainly
evidence of that finally on that one
what does sanctioning putin himself do
in this the opinion of this
administration a lot of analysts have
said that this is more of a symbolic
move than anything well without getting
into any specific details i know you're
not exactly asking me this but sort of
about financial assets etc i will leave
that to others to speak to
certainly the united uh uh this step
that we are doing in alignment uh and in
coordination with the europeans just
sends a clear message about uh the the
strength of the opposition uh to the
actions uh by president putin and the
direction uh in his leadership of the
russian military
yeah i just wanted to ask continuing the
questions on sanctions yeah um today we
said that the italian government and the
german government both expressed they
said very clearly that they would not
veto
uh a move to remove russia from the
swift transaction system
can you say a word about how quickly you
think something like that would happen
and whether you believe that that would
be another productive tool and perhaps
another moment you know symbolic
or rather important measure sure well um
again
the president's principle is doing
taking steps in alignment we are
stronger together especially as we stand
in the face of the uh russian military's
actions and and their invasion of
ukraine as it relates to swift we've
never taken that off the table of course
and i'm certainly not taking it off the
table today so certainly there'll be
ongoing discussions about that as you
know swift is a messaging service that
connects 11 000 uh banks and uh many
would argue that um there are ways that
um that russia the russian leadership
could get around that over the course of
time but it certainly remains an option
on the table in terms of the timeline i
don't have anything to predict for you
on that um we were
also reported today that china has
actually increased its reserves as
opposed to releasing reserves which
could help
with the energy price increases that
we're seeing have you uh had you know
what do you what do you think of that
move and then also has there been any
further communication does president of
biden intent to talk to president xi or
can you say a word about
what what you're doing in terms of
trying to convince the chinese to be
supportive
well i i would note that um also today
um the i the iea
um had an informal meeting where they
discussed options they could take over
the coming days and weeks to help
address uh any uh
volatility in the global markets and um
you know the heightening of price
volatility um and certainly that meeting
today was a chance to consult and
continue coordination with partners on
global energy supply and security uh
there's also continuing conversations
that we have had from here with partners
over the past day secretary granholm
spoke with french german eu and uk
counterparts yesterday and will continue
those conversations as it relates to
china uh you know i would say that
the president's view of course is that
now is the time for leaders of the world
to not just speak out clearly against
president putin's flagrant aggression
and to stand with the people of ukraine
uh but this is not a moment for
equivocation or hiding or waiting to see
what happens next it is already clear
what's happening and as a part of that
it's also important to be a part of the
effort to
mitigate and minimize the impact on
global markets and global oil markets
and so i don't have any additional
conversations to read out for you but i
would say certainly we all want to be
part of the solution here and stand up
in the face of aggression to help
address the problems are you saying that
china is in fact equivocating
all i'm saying is that every country
should think about what side of history
they want to be on here and they have
the ability to do that
go ahead when did president biden make
the final decision to sanction president
it was made it's been on the table for
some time but through coordination and
discussion with our european partners
over the last
day or so so he decided
in the last 24 hours that he was going
to do that again it's been on the table
for some time his priority and his focus
has been on taking steps in coordination
and obviously that decision uh was made
over the course of the last 24 hours and
in in partnership with our european
counterparts does it include a travel
ban by chance uh i believe that would be
a part of the us uh component yes so
president putin would be banned from
traveling here there's more details of
it that again will be out later today uh
there are very limited examples of this
being done as you all know um but that
is a standard part but again there'll be
more details we'll have available later
today another question on travel the uk
is banning civilian russian aircraft
from its airspace saying that no
aircraft on a service owned operated or
charted chartered by a person connected
with russia shall fly in their airspace
is the united states planning to do the
same
i'm not aware of that being in the plans
but i don't have anything to preview for
you okay and another question we've seen
these predictions from the defense
department from the state department
about
keem falling to russia yeah they've been
clear that they believe that as in
putin's sites and that he wants to
overthrow the government there
if that happens what does the us do what
is the response in the world that the
united states takes after something like
that happens
well i would just reiterate as we've
been warning for months
that keep falling as a real possibility
and we've continued to see
russia's
progression even as we've seen uh
resistance on the ground uh russia's
military contin russia's military
continues to advance toward heave so
there is that real possibility i'm just
not going to get into at this point
hypotheticals of what that will look
like or what our response would be thank
you go ahead thank you again
sanctions again
based on what you've said so far so
what's this decision to coordinate with
allies meant to show unity
meant to show that putin is a pariah or
do you think it will actually have an
impact on putin in practice given the
uncertainty about the extent and
location of his wealth sure i understand
what you're asking i'm just not going to
get into specifics about his financial
assets from here again i think what is
important and what we are hoping the
world takes away from this is the uh
unity uh through which the united states
president biden is working uh with our
european partners and allies without
getting into details can you even say if
this will or will not impact him other
than showing that he's you know
an outlier again i'm not going to get
into his personal financial assets
that's typically not something we would
do from here but i would note again that
the steps that were taken yesterday and
announced yesterday uh sanctioning uh
the ten largest financial ten of the
largest financial institutions in russia
accounting for a huge percentage of
their banking capacity uh what of their
financial system capacity i should say
and even the anticipation of that uh has
had an enormous impact on russia whether
it's the currency the ruble that has
fallen the markets uh skyrocketing
inflation in russia and we also have
taken steps to uh sanction uh oligarchs
around president putin people who have
benefited from
corruption and cronyism in the system
and even their family members to prevent
them from having the capacity to move
around their assets and on the supreme
court today
it was exactly two years ago today that
the president made a pledge that he
would nominate a black woman to the
supreme court did he factor the timing
of that into his decision to announce it
today no okay
um and then can you share any details
about the process sure now that it's
over finally we're free
you know how long the interview or
interviews were
what they talked about what led the
president to choose uh judge jackson
over the other candidates sure well i i
will share with you the details that
we're comfortable sharing at this point
in time and obviously judge jackson will
have uh be filling out a range of
questionnaires she will be testifying
she will be considered by the full
senate and she will be asked a range of
questions there uh the president
interviewed judge jackson judge childs
and judge krueger on monday february
14th in person uh he made his final
decision and called judge jackson last
night
last evening i would note it was after
the press briefing last evening the
president called uh leader schumer
senator mcconnell speaker pelosi and
whip clyburn all separately this morning
to inform them of his decision i'd also
note that the vice president has been
very engaged not just in the
decision-making process as the president
talked about during his remarks but she
called former president obama and former
president clinton
as well and she has also been calling a
range of members of congress as a part
of the announcement process they could
personally call um
krueger and childs to let them know that
he had chosen judge jackson i don't have
any other details on that uh but i can
tell you that he called judge jackson to
offer her the to tell her he was going
to nominate her last evening go ahead
thank you jen the state department just
said about the us and russia that there
are still some areas in which the
fulfillment of our national security
priorities and imperatives require us to
engage and co-exist how is it that we
are still
engaging and coexisting with the
russians well peter i would say
diplomacy around the world requires us
to engage with countries even where we
have
strong disagreements strong opposition
strong condemnation we have been very
outspoken and taken actions against
china's human rights abuses but we have
worked with them in other capacities we
are working russia as a part of the p5
plus one as we're working and making
progress on an iran nuclear deal there's
no question that achievement of that
would make the world safer uh so it is
our responsibility uh and and diplomacy
means engaging even with countries where
you have strong disagreement and strong
opposition just so that we can
understand that the approach that means
that you guys will sit here and sanction
vladimir putin and then send diplomats
to go sit on the same side of the table
with
the russians to hash out the iranian is
that what's happening
that's right peter but i don't know why
you sound so skeptical
what our job here in the united states
and from any government is to take steps
that are in the interests of the
american people and the united states of
america and part of that is would
certainly be reducing iran's capacity
and ability to have a nuclear weapon i
think there's no question about that
russia is a part of the p5 plus one okay
there's a report in the new york times
that you guys kept asking china to help
you stop russia from invading ukraine
and they didn't so
what have you guys done
throughout this slow-moving russian
crisis
that has worked
in what capacity well the president
talked to putin he talked to the g7 he
threatened sanctions he put sanctions in
place now he says the sanctions are
going to take 30 days
or about a month do you guys think the
people in ukraine have about a month
well peter let me just take a step back
and explain to everyone how diplomacy
works and how our approach from the
united states has worked uh what the
president has done is he has built a
global coalition uh to stand up in the
face of president putin and president
putin's aggression and uh invasion of
ukraine what he has done is he has
rallied the world our eu european
partners even at cost to them in some
capacities to put in place uh
significant sanctions historic sanctions
that would have a
a a enormous impact on the russian
financial sector it is president putin's
choice to go to war and invade ukraine
that is what he has done it is our
choice and our responsibility and the
role of the president and the united
states to rally opposition and make sure
they feel significant pain from that
choice that's exactly what we have done
and i understand that you're saying that
these sanctions will have an impact on
russia but what good does that do these
people in ukraine who are
seeing the news and these us intel
assessments that kiev is going to fall
any day well peter first of all we are
the largest provider of humanitarian
assistance of security assistance uh in
the world to the ukrainian to the
ukrainian government which still stands
and support and the biggest supporter of
the ukrainian people
and we will continue to be and we are
leading this global effort to stand up
against the aggression of president
putin and so we are doing the president
is doing nearly everything in his power
to lead the world and stand up against
the actions of president putin what he
will not do is send u.s troops to fight
in ukraine because he is not going to
put the american public the american
people or the united states in a
position of fighting a war with russia
go ahead if i can ask you about we've
been watching a lot of the pictures play
out from overseas we've seen anti-war
protesters rounded up and arrested in
moscow and elsewhere throughout russia
we've seen awful pictures coming from
throughout ukraine including one today
that was dramatic a russian tank
literally rolling over a ukrainian
civilian vehicle can you just give us a
sense is the president watching this
happen his reaction to this his message
to those anti-war protesters i mean it's
they're it's horrific to watch it's
heart-wrenching to watch and we've all
seen the images uh the president the
vice president members of our national
security team and it almost doesn't
matter how much you've been through how
many conflicts you've watched over time
and he has unfortunately watched many in
a variety of national security roles uh
to feel heartbroken by what you're
seeing and happen in ukraine in a
sovereign country uh that is as having
its right to exist threatened by russia
the aggressor in this case uh you know i
would say our message to the ukrainian
people uh continues to be that we stand
with you we support you we are going to
do everything humanitarian assistance
economic assistance continue to provide
security assistance and rally the world
to condemn the actions of president
putin
protesters in russia well first i think
we would say that uh we are we are
amazed by your courage um your
remarkable courage and standing up uh
against uh what uh president putin is
doing uh it is uh not easy uh to protest
in in many scenarios but it's certainly
not easy to protest against the actions
of an autocratic leader and that's
exactly what uh these protesters are
doing room i'll ask only one last
question which is is it relates to the
supreme court following up on the
questions here the president wanted it
to be a bipartisan process he's met with
many republicans chuck grassley the top
republican on senate judiciary committee
three republicans helped confirm judge
kataji brown jackson uh in the spring of
last year one of them lindsey graham
today said among other things
um that this selection means the radical
left is one president biden over yet
again the white house's response well i
think what's most important for
everybody to unknow and understand is
more about judge jackson's record and
what was very compelling to and to go
back to luigi's question sorry i didn't
answer this part um what was compelling
to the president i talked to him about
with him about this this morning and you
heard him lay this out in great detail
in his remarks you know judge jackson is
someone who uh very much is in the mold
of justice breyer having even clerked
for him she talked about that during his
remarks
when she was confirmed as a district
judge in 2013 judge breyer praised her
for being a
wise decision and swore her in and even
parts of their biography overlapped time
on the sentencing commission time as a
federal judge but it's also how she has
approached her role as a judge that was
very compelling to the president she's
issued opinions without regard to
partisan considerations she's ruled in
favor of republicans and democrats she's
ruled for and against the government
regardless of whether the government is
led by a democratic president or a
republican president litigants lawyers
and judges across the ideological
spectrum appreciate her ability to be an
impartial adjudicator and that's exactly
what you want as a judge she's even
clerked for three different federal
judges who were appointed by presidents
of different political parties so i
would just note all of that to suggest
that um you know anyone who is already
ruling her out without even meeting with
her engaging with her uh and reviewing
her extensive uh record as a fair uh and
just uh judge uh you know there may be
other reasons for that thank you come
back uh thanks does the use do you have
any update on the um
uh
hostages that were reported to be taken
at terminal i unfortunately don't have
an update on that um from here at this
point i can check for you after the
briefing does the us have any plans to
speed up the refugee processing
for ukrainians but do you want to come
to the us as they did with afghans they
want
the well it's it's a slightly different
circumstance i will say because our
assessment is that the majority of uh
refugees will want to go to neighboring
countries in europe many of which have
already conveyed publicly that they will
accept uh any refugee who needs a home
whether it's poland or germany and there
are probably others who have made those
comments so we are really working in
close lockstep with our european
counterparts about what the needs are
and how to help from our end uh meet
those needs uh we that certainly means
an openness to accepting refugees from
ukraine but also making sure that all of
these neighboring countries who are
willing to welcome these refugees uh you
know have our support in that effort go
ahead thanks jen um i know the white
house has said it won't be sending the
us won't be sending troops into ukraine
to rescue americans who are still there
so what is the us doing about americans
who are still left in ukraine as the
situation gets more dire well we i i
will first start by saying that we have
been warning for months now about the
dire circumstances developing in ukraine
and conveying very directly to american
citizens they should leave we have also
been in touch from the state department
with every american we can reach i would
point you to them for more specifics on
that and we continue to have the
capacity to uh you know help them
in a range of ways even as we don't have
a diplomatic uh presence in ukraine in
this i mean we don't have people in the
country right now obviously but they are
in neighboring countries i'd really
point you to the state department for
any more specifics president is
obviously now going to be in delaware
this weekend can you share what he will
be doing there will he be traveling with
members of his national security team
will he be receiving regular updates on
ukraine sure he will have a meeting with
members of his national security team
tomorrow in delaware i will note that
well every president can work from
anywhere they are because that is how
presidencies are equipped he is
traveling to delaware for the memorial
service of a family member uh and he
will be
that is why he is traveling there this
weekend
go ahead
just to follow up on my question does
the president have special secure
facilities in in wilmington we know that
obviously at camp david that is
something available um given the the
national security crisis is that thing
that is also available the president has
the capacity to make a secure call from
anywhere he is yes and then on on the
supreme court
is it to the president that um
the
judge jackson receives bipartisan uh
support if she is confirmed and how much
political capital and time and energy is
he personally going to put in um
to
getting republican support for the
nomination well i think tyler let me
flip this around a little bit for you
and just say the president's view is
that when you look at somebody like
judge jackson who has is extraordinarily
qualified has impeccable credentials
she has been allotted by a former
speaker of the house paul ryan who said
on her behalf
last when she was put forward last year
i know she's clearly qualified but it
bears repeating just how qualified she
is our politics may differ but my praise
for contagi's intellect for her
character for her intellect is
unequivocal uh that she is somebody who
has and i would also note that former dc
district judge thomas griffith appointed
by president george w bush publicly
supported her d.c court nomination and
she received a bipartisan letter of
support from individuals who co-clerked
along judge jackson so i think the bar
here should not be
what is the president going to do of
course he's going to engage with
democrats and republicans you've seen
him operate in that way to date it is
what are republicans going to do in
terms of considering an eminently
qualified uh judge that the president is
nominated who by many standards has
exhibited had shown herself to uh issue
opinions without regard to partisan
considerations uh and ruled in a way
that certainly uh anyone regardless of
their political affiliation would be
proud to see
just one more quick point on the state
of the union um how much is that speech
being
changed by
the russian ukraine crisis can you just
give us a little bit of a preview about
what we may hear from the president on
tuesday i certainly understand the
question but i can't give you a preview
of a speech four days from now uh quite
yet about and how it will address in a
developing conflict
right yeah uh president biden stated
from the outset and you've reiterated
that reiterated today that he won't send
us troops to ukraine to fight russians
given the high stakes uh you know
president biden yesterday said uh russia
has aspirations beyond ukraine why isn't
this a fight worth sending us troops for
why in europe
why has the president assessed that
shouldn't be an option well i i would
say first it's important to note that we
have uh certainly uh made clear not just
by words but by actions that we are
going to continue to support and even
plus up our support for nato defense
operations and there was an announcement
yesterday of an increase of additional 7
000 troops and obviously there was a
significant announcement made today by
nato uh we are uh fir we will firmly
stand behind our article five
obligations but i would say as it
relates to sending u.s troops into
ukraine uh the president the role of the
president of the united states any
president is to make an assessment about
what is in the interest of the united
states our national security interests
the american people and certainly weigh
very heavily uh how we're leading the
global community but it is not in our
interest to be in a war with russia and
so no we are not sending u.s troops to
ukraine up front uh that this is not an
option didn't president biden take away
what could have been a threat to deter
uh putin from invading and to further uh
uh push into ukraine i think the
president
believes he has a responsibility to be
very direct with the american people
about what his intentions are and what
his intentions are not and that is his
first priority as president finally what
was the white house's reaction to
president zolinski's uh today uh in a
video address saying that ukraine has
been left alone to defend itself against
russia well as you know uh the president
spoke with uh president zielinski and
made clear to him during that
conversation that he and he commended
his brave uh leadership his brave
actions the brave actions of the
ukrainian people who were fighting to
defend their country he also conveyed
our ongoing economic humanitarian and
security support that we will continue
to provide so that is hardly standing on
the sidelines we are providing again the
largest provider of security economic
humanitarian assistance of any country
in the world and we will continue to uh
support uh president zilenski and
ukrainian people the white house doesn't
think he's been left alone
i think i'll leave it at that go ahead
thanks a lot tim does the administration
have any plans to offer tps to
ukrainians who are in the united states
or who who might end up coming to the
united states does it support the idea
well there it's a process that would be
overseen by the interagency through go
through an interagency process led by
the department of homeland security i
know there are many advocates for that
but i don't have an update on the
process or if it will happen
what plans uh does the administration in
regard to refugees what plans does the
administration have to take in uh for
the united states to take in some
refugees in the united states have there
been any planning discussions perhaps
with refugee groups uh to prepare this
do you have an anticipated number of how
many refugees may come to this i don't
have an updated and anticipated number
to project what i will convey to you is
that we are always in constant contact
with the refugee organizations who do
incredible work around the world but i
would also reiterate that what we've
seen happen over the last couple of days
as countries like poland germany and
others in europe make clear that they
are going they are opening their arms to
welcome refugees from ukraine those are
neighboring countries so we do
anticipate the vast majority will uh
want to go to countries in europe would
you anticipate that some would come to
the united we are open to that yes
and if i could ask one more senator
coons floated the idea of 10 billion a
10 billion dollar emergency supplemental
package just uh does the administration
support that proposal we are having
ongoing conversations uh with congress
about additional assistance to ukraine
uh our omb leadership is having those
conversations and so i will leave it to
them to put out any updated specific
number from our end but those are
underway go ahead um why doesn't uh
president obama talk to vladimir putin
right now
because he's invading a sovereign
country
isn't he gonna be potentially invading
that for years
well i would say that a moment where a
leader is is a beginning and in the
middle of invading a sovereign country
is not the moment where
diplomacy feels appropriate it does not
mean we have ruled out diplomacy forever
obviously the president remains open to
engaging on at a leader to leader level
but this is not the moment
why are you guys waiting to apply
maximum pressure on russia with you know
sanctions on everything
it doesn't seem you know are you guys
waiting for kyo to fall or sanctions on
everything how do you mean captions on
all russian
you know all russian transactions and
oil and gas or like do you do you think
that americans are not willing to
take
a hit up the gas pump well well i i
would say there's a couple of um
principles uh through which the
president has approached sanctions um
one is maximizing the impact on uh
russian leadership and on uh on the
russian financial system so that there
will be a particular squeeze we've
obviously taken steps already that have
gone far and above what have ever been
done what has ever been done in the past
if you look at just 10 the 10 financial
institutions that we sanctioned
they hold a a huge percentage of they're
about 80 percent of the russian banking
sector that is a significant step that
was announced yesterday the export
controls step that was announced
yesterday means that they will be uh
they won't have the ability to get
access to the technology that and and
semiconductors and ai that president
putin desperately wants to continue to
innovate his economy moving forward
there's also of course europeans are
also looking at european countries are
also looking at some of their reliance
on russia whether it's for energy or
other purposes and they're making their
own decisions about diversifying and as
i noted a little bit earlier the ruble
remains about 10 weaker year-to-date and
the worst performing emerging market
currency in the world so what should be
clear here is that there are already
huge impacts there is already an
enormous squeeze on the russian uh
financial system and economy what we are
also what the president is also focused
on as a principal is
not is taking steps making sure we are
minimizing the impact on the american
people on the global economic system and
we of course weigh that as we have a
responsibility to do and we want to
first and foremost i should have said
this first take these steps united with
our uh partners and allies in europe
does the administrators have any message
to american companies that do business
in russia with entities that are not
necessarily on the sanction list would
you like to see u.s citizens
not buy russian products would you like
to see us based ceos not look for
business in russia we're not trying to
hurt the people of russia or the russian
people we're trying to squeeze the
financial system and sector to uh to
make sure there are significant
consequences for the actions of the
president go ahead
so understanding there's no plans for
presidents uh biden and putin to speak
is there any line of communication
between the white house and the kremlin
right now
uh i don't have additional details on
that at this point in time obviously our
national security team has a range of
means of communicating with the russians
what you said earlier in your answer to
mean that the president won't speak with
putin unless putin de-escalates or
withdraws well again it's not the
appropriate moment right now i can't
give you i'm not going to give you a
forever or never because that's not how
he feels but uh they are actively
invading uh ukraine they are moving on
the capital uh they are looking to
overturn leadership this uh is is not
the moment for president biden to to
have a diplomatic conversation with
president putin one more on refugees
it's been noted that the eu response to
ukrainian refugees has been quite
different to the response to refugees
from other nations and i wonder what the
white house view is on that given that
some countries like poland and hungary
were actively trying to keep out many
refugees largely from the middle east
well uh
i i don't think i have any further
comment on that from here about the
decisions of other countries and where
they accept refugees from what i can
speak to is what our approach is here in
the united states and obviously we have
welcomed uh with open arms tens of
thousands of afghan refugees and
certainly well it may be to to go to the
earlier question that the majority of
refugees from ukraine go to europe we
are certainly open to
accepting refugees from ukraine as well
that is our policy and our approach and
certainly what we will continue to
implement
just following up on the questions and
your discussion of club sanctioning oil
and gas
and an understanding that the president
in in any decisions he makes around
sanctions or any other actions you think
against russia is thinking about the
american people
is there a point at which he would
consider doing that but that is that
like the energy sector
if the energy sector stops at some level
on the table it's
putin gets even more aggressive and also
you know there are also some other
countries that
um are have worked for carve outs for
instance italy and luxury goods what is
the u.s view of those kinds of
exceptions being made for things that
are maybe a lot a lot less essential as
much as we might like them um than oil
and gas
speaking for yourself
so i would say in the energy sector no
option is off the table but again to go
back to the principle some of the
principles here our sanctions are
designed to harm russia's economy not
our economy and that's a key balance
that we're clearly trying to strike and
i think when delete as delete has been
in here a few times over the last week
he's conveyed we do risk assessments
right and impact assessments um and
that's a part of it uh the other factor
here on the energy sector is that
starting out with energy or could
actually benefit uh president putin and
pad his pockets because given high oil
and gas prices cutting off russian oil
and gas could drive prices up to uh
putin's benefit so that's obviously a
factor as well but it's not off the
table but we look at a range of
issues in terms of how what what other
countries have fought as far as part of
their area but they're not functioning
does the administration have a view of
that
i don't think i think look our focus
right now is that
we are we are working in close
coordination and in lockstep with our
european counterparts it does not mean
everything is identical it is not
identical but what you have seen across
the board is very strong impactful
sanctions that uh the shared hope is
that they will have significant economic
and financial consequences
does the administration have an estimate
of how many russian deaths or casualties
there have been in ukraine
i don't have that assessment from here i
don't expect we would have that
assessment from here
that they've been putting out for 2 800
they've been putting out today
do you have any sense of the accuracy or
the order of magnitude i i don't have
any assessment from here and i don't
anticipate we would i know that the
department of defense is providing is
doing regular or daily nearly uh
briefings on kind of the movements and
what they're seeing on the ground but i
don't believe even they were able to
make an assessment of casualties uh
earlier today one more question on the
supreme court process um you mentioned
three candidates that he interviewed in
person
uh just want to make sure it's the only
three candidates he interviewed in
person the interview any candidates
virtually those are the candidates he
interviewed okay yes
yeah
go ahead do you have another one okay
go ahead
stand by the support you guys gave to
brazil to become a global partner and
nato after president boson automatic
last week with president putin and still
president bolsonaro didn't condemn the
invasion
again as i said in relation to a
question a little bit earlier i mean our
uh view and our of our our push for
every country in the world is to stand
up in this moment and decide what where
you stand uh where where you want to be
in history as the history books look
back uh but that doesn't i don't have
anything in terms of our change of
review of our overarching relationship
go ahead here can i just follow up on
that question in terms of building a
global coalition against russia right i
mean india for example a plot member
it's the only part member that's not
implementing uh export controls for
example i think the president yesterday
mentioned that that issue still hasn't
been resolved is he planning to pull
prime minister modi i think prime
minister modi called president putin
yesterday uh and just can you speak more
broadly in terms of bringing all these
other partners that maybe you know not
in europe but you know the quad as well
as perhaps asean members were
pretty uh ambivalent and cautious about
condemning the russian invasion
i would say some were but i wouldn't say
the majority were
and we continue to engage with the
indians with other asean partners on
both what we're seeing on the ground uh
uh are our continued condemnation of the
actions of president putin uh in ukraine
uh and we will continue to uh push
others to follow suit just to follow up
delta announced today that they're
suspending code sharing with aeroflot
did the white house have anything to do
with the decision and are you urging
other american companies to
uh urge them to be the same that's a
decision by a private sector company so
i don't have any more comments under the
state of the union okay preview a little
bit on the foreign policy portion of the
president's state of the union i mean
obviously with the crisis in ukraine i
know that you you're not going to be
able to preview that but just in general
now with ukraine before that with the
afghanistan withdrawal what can the
president say to show that his foreign
policy doctrine is succeeding
well
without previewing the state of the
union which we'll do later this evening
or later this weekend sorry it's kind of
all one day that's running together
um we will do later this weekend i
expect so look at look ahead to that or
we'll have more to say later this
weekend you know it's also as it relates
to russia ukraine you know we are
unfortunately still in the middle of
this conflict right we are in the middle
of an active invasion so i just can't
give you a preview of what that will
look like in the state of the union
as it relates to
how the president views his approach to
foreign policy
you know the president has
ran for president wanting to return
america's seat at the world wanting to
return uh to a time where uh other
leaders around the world could trust the
word and the commitments of the united
states and what you have seen over the
last few months is the president deliver
on exactly that he has been leading the
effort in the world to stand up to
russia stand up to the efforts the
aggression uh the invasion of a
sovereign country um well i'm not going
to get into the specifics of of what is
going to be in the state of the union
that's exactly what he said he would do
when he was running go ahead
the president said he's doing everything
he can to bring down um energy prices
yes prices here in the us um is on the
table then or is he considering
reversing some of the policies and
regulations that they put into place
that constricts the long-term supply
that to let europe be more reliant on
the u.s for oil and natural gas you mean
like lng exports or something like that
but also oil prices allowing you know
opening up drilling again
reversing the ban on leases
on federal lands well well i think
what's important to note here and i
talked about this a little bit yesterday
is that um there are a range of
available oil leasing sites that oil
companies are not utilizing so you
should ask them about that you know the
president's view on on reducing our
dependence on foreign oil and actually
his view is that this makes that case
even stronger
and diversifying the range of means of
energy production everywhere around the
world as it relates to lng exports i
don't have anything new on that our
focus right now is on working with um or
engaging with a range of countries i
mentioned japan yesterday and having
conversations with others who may have
the availability of supply natural gas
supply that was coming from the united
states to provide to europe in this time
where they need it and we're seeing some
encouraging developments on that front
opec is making moves now to get ready to
include iranian oil um in if the us is
successful with the iran nuclear deal uh
would the president then welcome iranian
oil coming into the u.s to lower gas
prices well again uh we're not quite at
the point of a final deal on uh the
nuclear deal so we will talk about that
if we get to that point
thanks you've talked a couple times
about the us engaging in diplomacy with
russia going forward when he announced
the sanctions today against putin and
lavrov the british prime minister told
nato leaders that there could be no
normalization with russia after the
attack on ukraine does this
administration share that view well
again in this moment um
the i've conveyed pretty clearly the
president has no intentions at this
moment to engage with president putin uh
he was just sanctioned we just made a
decision in coordination in close
lockstep with the europeans to uh
sanction him a head of state that is a
very rare step to take and obviously
we've issued significant sanctions that
cover 80 percent of the financial sector
so no we're not in a business as usual
moment at this point in time and
obviously de-escalation would help
return us to a state where that could
proceed the white house right now
believe that president zielinski is safe
in keith we are in uh close touch with
him well i'm not going to give you
updates on his security uh state uh we
uh certainly the president just spoke
with him earlier today and he continues
to be the president of ukraine
good
all right in regards to the
new cdc guidance on the pandemic yeah
which of course will then be the you
know
the new uh fight administration guidance
what is the
what will the message be to americans in
regards to these new metrics and this
the new guidance as to where we are
independent
well i would say um
if you look at the specific of them
where we are moving the president we've
talked a little bit about how we want to
move to a time and a place where we are
uh uh you know have the tools needed so
that kovid and the pandemic uh did not
disrupt our daily lives uh obviously
they'll ha there's more the president's
been talking to his koba team about
exactly that this is a part of that
process um and we're moving forward in
that process
as a result of these this announcement
today and these updated recommendations
today more than half the country 70 of
americans live in areas where the cdc no
longer recommends universal masking
obviously if people want to wear a mask
because they're immunocompromised
because uh they have concerns about
their safeties and their safety in their
communities they should have the ability
to do that but that is certainly a step
forward so um you know that this is part
of uh that process and i expect we'll
have more to say soon concern that this
might um imply or
have have folks think that then
therefore the pandemic is over and can
issue
all caution and then secondly are kind
of added on to that um are you confident
that there will be an ability to reverse
course if things get bad again well uh
if if nobody is saying it's uh means
it's over including anybody who has a
big platform for example then that we're
not concerned about that that is not
what we're conveying from here right
what we are conveying from here and what
the cdc is conveying is that america is
in a stronger place today uh as a nation
uh we have more tools ever than ever
before to protect ourselves from covet
19 vaccination boosters treatments
testing high quality masks improved
ventilation over 200 million people are
vaccinated nearly 100 million americans
have been boosted and the cdc is
providing public health guidance that
has a couple of different clear levels
uh so that people can understand what
their recommendation is as it relates to
wearing a mask that's exactly what this
is there are still people dying every
day of covid there are still
immunocompromised populations
but what we are trying to work towards
is a period of time where we are
where covet is not disrupting our daily
lives
uh go ahead i just wanted to know you
said that the president has done
everything in his power we've seen the
sanctions shoring up the nato eastern
flank all of that but no troops
repeated that
doesn't that also send the message to
vladimir putin clearly it hasn't stopped
him that other
nations in the region that are not nato
members are also free game for him since
he's not going to have that stock well i
don't think the crippling sanctions that
the president has issued or approved and
we announced yesterday that cover 80 of
the financial sector that are having
an impact already on the financial
sector there or steps that the president
has taken including export getting
export controls or steps he's taken to
sanction oligarchs and to rally the
world to
to take not only uh
significant financial steps but also to
treat
president putin as a pariah send a
message that there's a free walk for
anything in fact president putin is
isolating himself further he's if if his
objective here is to
has his stated objective is to divide
nato if his stated objective is to
divide uh the west um it's having the
opposite effect so uh i i don't think
that would be our assessment
go ahead can i just uh just a quick
question on cyber attacks yeah the nato
secretary general again said that
he would view a cyber attack on a nato
member this time talking about nato
members as
something that would
be under article five is that the view
of the united states also that is cyber
yeah i answered this yesterday and i
said that it would be up to nato members
uh to determine what that looks like and
what any response would look like go
ahead has the president been in touch
with before after the decision today
with congressman clyburn he of course
was a big booster yeah he called him
this morning
thank you okay one more one more last
one thank you oh go ahead yeah thank you
jen
[Music]
you've said you said that the u.s will
not go to war against russia obviously
russia is heavily um the u.s is ugly um
and i'm i'm just wondering if you're not
being pragmatic here in russia
have you not been pragmatic to recognize
that it may not be in the interest of
the u.s for ukraine to be a member of
nato which is the key
request from russia
i'm not sure i'm understanding your
question is it are you asking me if
in the interest of the us for ukraine to
be a member of nato it is up to every
country to determine what alliances they
want to join or not join and that is not
a pressure point we issue from the
united states and we think it's
important for that to remain
open for a job
uh i have uh more than enough on my
plate here and so you can't get rid of
me quite yet sorry peter for you on that
um
and so i will see you all on monday
thank you everyone
thank you
oh